marching on an island
they say has been poisoned by pesticide
thousands demand justice for a crime
they say is two decades in the making
it is absolutely necessary to be here
today to fight the criminals
those who have polluted martinique those
who are destroying us
those who have already deported our
ancestors who enslaved
our ancestors who today want to poison
us
want to see us disappear enough is
enough now
nearly all adults living on martinique
and neighboring guadalupe have traces of
claudicone in their blood
tons of the chemical was sprayed on
banana crops
contaminating soil rivers and coastal
waters
it's been blamed for a high incidence of
cancer
and residents believe the french
government should be held accountable
anger is beginning to seriously
translate there is no question
of a statute of limitation for the chain
of crimes that have been committed
against us
against nature and against the humans of
this country
it is not possible that the state which
bears a large part of the responsibility
will not take steps for a true
reparation of the damage that has been
caused
claudicone sold under its commercial
name capone was created in the u.s in
the 1950s
it was banned there in 1976 after
several contamination incidents
the world health organization has
classified it as potentially
carcinogenic
experts say it also affects children's
nervous systems
in children and those people who now
have it in their bodies
the cancer rate on the island is out of
control
it really is a dangerous and damaging
pesticide banned
long ago in france and most of the world
but permitted in that island uh far too
long
french president emmanuel macron has
previously called it an environmental
scandal
but the future of the case is unclear
the high tribunal of magistrates in
paris says some evidence has disappeared
and the damage may have happened too
long ago
to now claim compensation
the people of martinique however remain
defiant
and are calling on the french government
to give them the justice they've been
waiting on for 15 years
hamera chaudhary al jazeera